a NASA satellite passes over the shallow
waters of the Indian Ocean it sends back
images of a chain of largely submerged
objects running between Sri Lanka and
India it looks like a string of pearls
between two islands it looks to me like
a rocky jetty but this thing looks
pretty big on closer analysis of the
satellite image
investigators calculate the line of
rocks is over 30 miles long what makes
the image especially intriguing is that
the rocks are in an area of C mentioned
in an ancient Hindu poem a poem which
also refers to a magic bridge their
Hindu legends that the god Rama
placed a bridge here connecting India to
Sri Lanka
the stones in the satellite image are
sitting on something oh she nog refers
call a shoal or sandbar these occur in
an area where there's shallow waters and
sand could accumulate between the two
land masses the sandbar may be natural
but what's sitting on top of it is not
this isn't just a simple sandbar
there's objects in here that haven't
been eroded away there are stones that
have been brought from afar and set on
top of our sandbar island chain how
these stones got here is a mystery and
what a team of geologists date the
stones the mystery deepens the rocks on
top of the sand actually predate the
sand so there's more to the story
scientific analysis reveals the rocks
are seven thousand years old
but are sitting on top of sand that is
only four thousand years old these
results suggest the structure in the
satellite image isn't natural but built
by humans some scholars believe the
ancient texts referred to a time 5,000
years ago at this point in history
buildings such a long bridge would have
been a superhuman achievement